Welcome back everyone this will be my joker 2
teaser video they just dropped a brand new teaser
trailer in a release date for joker 2 confirming
that lady gaga is going to be playing a version
of harley quinn during the movie if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos of course i'll do more videos
when they release more footage for the film
of course everyone's asking about the big warner
brothers hbo max announcement i will address that
later in the video too like this is relatively
insulated from what's happening with hbo max
because it's like a completely separate thing
completely separate continuity like it's not
even tied to the matt reeves batman continuity
that he's setting up which itself is kind of
like his own separate universe but recently you
probably saw on your feeds todd phillips dropped
a teaser for joker 2 with joaquin phoenix like
the movie is real it actually exists now and
they'll get ready to shoot it really soon there
was a title reveal and the full script like it's
basically good to go because they're getting ready
to film it the title is pronounced joker Folie à
deux its french for joker shared madness
as in joker's shared psychotic episode
it's a term in psychology used to describe when
multiple people share the same delusion the same
psychotic episode in the context of the movie it
has multiple meanings it's about how the joaquin
phoenix arthur joker character has this sort of
madness delusion about the world living in gotham
city this delusion about being thomas wayne's
illegitimate son this also confirms now that
the title shared delusions so to speak refers
to the shared delusion that joker will share
with dr harleen quinzal during his stay at arkham
asylum there's a lot of reports that say that most
of the movie will take place in and around arkham
asylum so it'll deal with the development of their
relationship like how he meets her for the first
time how she eventually falls in love with him and
eventually he winds up twisting her to the dark
side so to speak they've kind of addressed that
in previous batman projects like they did a little
bit during the previous suicide squad movies with
the margot robbie version of harley quinn we saw
a little bit of her origin story as harley quinn
it sounds like a lot of this movie is just
going to be a much bigger version of that
also because it's still going to be relatively low
budget it makes sense that they would keep a lot
of it in and around arkham asylum it'll be really
interesting to see what she looks like compared
to the margot robbie version of harley quinn i
had to cut out a little bit of the music from
the teaser trailer just for copyright reasons but
this is what the actual audio sounds like on it
it's playing that classic song i'm in heaven which
is just meant to reference the context of their
relationship like this is happening in arkham
asylum like it's a reference to the fantasy that
is taking place in his head you're never quite
sure if what's happening is really happening
or if it's just happening inside his head and
now obviously because it's a shared delusion
is it happening inside her head as well it also
means that through his actions the crimes he pulls
off during the sequel on the scale that he does
that he's going to cause the rest of the city
that we saw towards the end of the first movie to
share in his madness metaphorically and literally
because we are talking about the joker here like
in some batman stories the comics the animated
series the tv shows the movies all the different
versions you see joker try to dose the city with
his joker serum the laughing serum in the context
of arthur's joker character in the first movie it
was more of a metaphorical thing because the crowd
was already in the middle of rioting because of
the current state of gotham city in this big class
divide in what was going on with the mayoral race
and thomas wayne's run for mayor the fun fact
about the joker serum 2 is that it's actually
derived from the scarecrow fear toxin but we
haven't had the scarecrow inside the joaquin
phoenix joker universe yet and even though it is
possible that he could use some version of the
joker serum during this joker sequel i don't
think they're gonna play it that way i think
they'll keep it in the realm of metaphor when
he talks about sharing his madness with everyone
like through his actions through the media people
will watch it like the people who are writing
it'll just get crazier and crazier and crazier and
he'll start to win them over through his actions
and they will then begin to share in his madness
it's not like he's gonna go around dumping a bunch
of fear toxin or joker toxin into the water supply
that's the really cool the really insidious thing
about the first joker movie is that he doesn't
need any kind of joker toxin like that it's all
about the role of the media and all this like in
the case of the first movie it was his broadcast
at the end that helped push his exploits to
legendary status but at the time he was already
building on an existing system of riots that
all the people in gotham had been upset about
the current administration the growing problems in
the city the whole inequality between the common
people who were rioting in the ultra rich people
represented by thomas wayne bruce wayne's family
he was in the middle of running for mayor
and there were these escalating series of
riots throughout the movie as things got crazier
and crazy and crazier public outcries during his
appearances eventually before he went full
joker at the end of the movie he called the
crowd a bunch of clowns so already things were
going really crazy in the city and what was
happening with the joker just kind of tipped that
over the edge the whole thing with him secretly
being thomas wayne's son i think was actually a
bit of a misdirect but the way the movie plays it
they want to be kind of ambiguous about it because
you're meant to be viewing everything in the film
from arthur's perspective so as he descends into
madness you're meant to see things get crazier
and weirder and weirder like they wanted you to
feel as if there might have been a possibility
that he was thomas wayne's son and they never
confirmed that it wasn't true even though they
implied that it was all just this big delusion in
reality i think that his mother had suffered from
mental delusions like he does in the movie like
she had had mental episodes when she was younger
and she just fell in love with thomas wayne
when her family was working at his mansion
and started to get creepy at his house and
then they just imply that his family kind
of pushed her family out the door like okay
you go off on your own no more working for us
and she just descended into a form of madness and
just came up with this delusion that she had been
in a relationship with thomas wayne when that
really wasn't the case so he's not really thomas
wayne's son but during the movie you notice even
after thomas wayne yells at him and they have that
episode together that big encounter he calls him
a crazy person arthur does not stop believing that
it's true he's still obsessed with the waynes
so the idea is that he had played a party clown
and thomas wayne had called the people like him
like the lower class people a bunch of clowns
acting crazy he started to feel like his life was
a joke eventually he just kind of owns all that by
wearing the name as his own mantle calling himself
the joker matt reeves actually had his version of
the barry kyokin joker in the batman movie kind
of say something similar like it's not so bad
being a clown the big difference during the
batman movie though is the ages of the batman
and the joker and the joker is in prison in arkham
asylum because batman put him there they released
a deleted scene that was meant to be on the one
year anniversary of him putting him in prison
so the barry kyogen joker was joking about that
with him like isn't it our anniversary present
isn't it so if it wasn't clear now obviously
matt reeves has confirmed that the joker in
his universe is not going to be the joaquin
phoenix versus the joker and even though they
are doing all this crazy multiverse stuff with the
flash movie the joaquin phoenix joker movie will
still be set in an alternate universe it's still
going to be rated r is still going to be part of
dc's black label which is what they're using for
their darker more hardcore films especially ones
that are set in alternate universes that aren't
necessarily connected to all the big dc eu stuff
most of the plot details are being kept in
an underground bunker as you would expect but
based on what both phillips and phoenix had said
previously the movie isn't going to have like a
massive time jump the original movie took place
during 1981 joaquin phoenix is in his 50s in
present day and real world but he was playing a 30
40 something joker so any references to batman or
any of the other pre-existing dc characters in the
joker sequel is just meant to be a coincidence or
in the case of this version of batman just
a totally new different version of batman
the joker sequel is mostly just meant
to move forward a little in the timeline
to the next logical event in gotham so bruce wayne
would still be a child living with alfred he'd be
a little bit older but still be a child and there
wouldn't be a bunch of batman stuff happening yet
the other really big change that you probably
just heard about that i mentioned earlier was todd
phillips separately being asked by the new powers
that be at dc at warner brothers to come in and
advise on doing more films kind of like the joker
in the same vein like talking about more dc black
label types of movies that means more mid-budget
movies like movies that are closer to like 90 100
million dollars about villain characters different
from what you would think of your traditional big
superhero type of dc film like a batman movie matt
reeves has talked about doing lots of spin-offs
for his characters like there's the arkham asylum
tv show there's the other batman based tv shows
on the robert pattinson version of batman that's
not meant to be dc black label stuff all the stuff
that todd phillips would be doing or helping
advisor producing at warner brothers if other
directors come on to do them is meant to be a
different line of continuity so todd phillips
would probably swerve on doing a black label
riddler film but there's many many other villains
in the dc toy box that they could do personally i
actually think that's been one of dc's strengths
they just announced that marvel is finally doing a
thunderbolts movie and they said that they pitched
it kind of like the marvel version of a suicide
squad film one of dc's big advantages over marvel
the past couple years has been their willingness
to do r-rated villain-based films this also kind
of gets into what's going on with the bloodbath
that was happening at hbo max recently with all
the cancellations of tv shows and movies what they
were mostly canceling with like the batgirl movie
for instance is movies that they had originally
just exclusively made for hbo max like they're
not doing that anymore no more mid-budget just for
hbo max they're just doing theatrical films now
and that's basically what todd phillips plan
always was like this was always going to be a
theatrical joker 2 movie all the dc black label
stuff that he might wind up doing in the future
that's all intended for a theatrical release
but what will happen is i'll do a separate
video if they make any more big announcements
about the future of dc films if they make any
other big plans because they're still planning
on hiring themselves sort of their own version
of a kevin feige figure to lead everything there's
a couple of the big trailers and a couple of the
big announcements that just happened i'll try to
do videos for everything as quickly as possible
everyone click here to learn about what's going on
with them ending the flash cancelling the batgirl
movie and click here for my new guardians
of the galaxy 3 trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!